how's it going everybody it's Warren and
today marks only two more weeks until
Avengers end game hits theaters and the
closer we get to the movie the more we
get for it
we have magazine articles coming out
posters coming out it seems like we get
new footage at least once a week at this
point as well and today I'm going to be
talking about an entire Avengers in game
plot leaked and this one is very
different than all of the other ones
that we've heard so far all of the other
ones that I've heard are sort of just
based off of the information that is
already given to us by Marvel from the
trailers and from photos but as always
I'll give my normal disclaimer there's
really no way to tell if this plot leak
is real or not
but this one does seem to be more legit
than all the other ones I've heard so in
case it ends up being true spoiler alert
also if you're new to my channel be sure
to subscribe so you can stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers in
game and I also do monthly giveaways
right now giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet and a Thanos painting
by global if you'd like to enter for
your chance to win all you have to do is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain so this plot leak comes from a
French redditor who says he saw the
movie two months ago before it was even
done with its editing so the editing
wasn't done the CGI wasn't done and the
music score wasn't done yet and the user
also said that there was no post credit
scene shown so again this was a French
redditor who posted this on reddit and
then it was translated into English so
if some things sound a tiny bit off it's
most likely due to a translation error
so I'll go ahead and read the plot
leaked line by line but again this is
for the full movie so this is your last
chance to leave if you want to avoid all
possible spoilers the movie opens on fan
OHS he is on Titan 2 and he's very happy
that he performed the snap then flashes
to Tony Stark stranded in space nebula
walks in and says that they're running
out of oxygen fast
Tony records his message to Pepper Potts
and then after he's done he gets a
sudden burst of inspiration and he
begins to try and fix the ship so he can
make it back home right after this the
title card with the Avengers logo comes
on back at Earth at the avengers
headquarters banner cap NAT and Rhodey
are talking about Thanos when they hear
a knock on the door it's agent Klein
from shield with Nick Fury's pager he
gives them the page
and tells them that Nick Fury is gone
banner then takes it and analyzes it
finding that it's sending a signal but
it's losing power not and cap go and
have a talk about everything and then
Steve and Rhodey go to a snap support
group banner and NAT talked about the
Hulk banner once again tries to bring
the Hulk out but the Hulk again refuses
Captain Marvel eventually shows up at
the avengers headquarters asking where's
fury the Avengers at the headquarters
fill her in on everything that has
happened with fan OHS and the Infinity
Gauntlet Tony Stark and nebula managed
to fix the ship and get to the nearest
jump point that takes them back to earth
there's a tiny reunion with the Avengers
and Tony Stark and Pepper Potts but it's
short-lived because Tony Stark needs
medical attention all the Avengers
except for Bruce and Tony start talking
about what they can do
nebula says that she knows where Thanos
is and then rocket pinpoints an energy
source that matches the Infinity
Gauntlet the Avengers go to fan OHS to
fight him but are easily defeated Thanos
holds Captain Marvel by the neck but
Thor saves her she is depowered a lot
Thor uses Stormbreaker to bring them
back to earth where banner is treating
Tony banner goes over to a weakened
Captain Marvel and asked to scan her and
she agrees Tony and banner look at the
results and are stunned by it they
decide that they need to try and copy
the Infinity stones but realize they
don't have the technology to do it Tony
and Pepper leave
Captain Marvel goes with Thor to find
his people and rocket stays with banner
trying to find a way to time travel
there's a time jump forward and
eventually ant-man comes out of the
quantum realm and goes to the Avengers
headquarters and explains to the
Avengers about the time vortexes with
some time passing Tony Stark Bruce
Banner and ant-man figure out how to
time travel
they've also figured out a way how to
copy the power of the Infinity stones
and Tony begins to work on a new
Infinity Gauntlet that would be capable
of harnessing all of the power of the
Infinity stones they decide that they
just can't go back in time to take the
Infinity stones because the effects of
altering the past could drastically
change the future too much so the
Avengers go back in time to copy the
Infinity stones from each place they
remember having seen them nebula tells
The Avengers about the soul stone on
Boromir but she tells them that they
need to get ready to lose someone they
love Captain America says no because
they've lost too many already so they
make a plan to go and fight past Thanos
on vermeer banner Tony Thor and Captain
America go to fight pass Thanos and Thor
nearly defeats Thanos but then Thanos
uses the powers
on him Tony uses a new device from his
new Ironman suit that stuns thanos for a
minute so that banner can copy the stone
he does and they get out of there
meanwhile present Thanos finds out about
their plan and he goes to the Avengers
headquarters when the Avengers are
exiting the quantum realm he is there
waiting with his outriders Thanos is
enraged and he starts his attack
thornton captain marvel defend the start
gauntlet with everything they have
during this attack Bruce Banner finally
becomes the Hulk and he goes for Thanos
Thanos uses the mine stone on the Hulk
and tries to make him turn on the
Avengers but the mine stone ends up
merging the two and the Hulk attacks him
Thanos and the Hulk go at it and Thanos
almost defeats the holt but Thor jumps
in to help the rest of the Avengers jump
in and attack Thanos as well but fan OHS
uses the Infinity Gauntlet to defeat the
Avengers and to destroy Starks Infinity
Gauntlet thanos then stomps on the
Avengers logo and gives them a speech on
why he did the snap but in the middle of
Fanus speech war machine blasts him with
a proton cannon and then Thanos uses the
space stone to retreat Tony realizes
that his Infinity Gauntlet is now
destroyed but Hawkeye says that he has
tracked down some arou metal Hawkeye
tells the Avengers where it is
so they go to where it is defeat some
arms dealers who have it and take the
ARU medal for themselves Tony takes the
medal back to the Avengers headquarters
and forges a new Infinity Gauntlet the
Hulk wields it and uses it to bring all
of the fallen heroes back but loses his
arm in the process
Tony builds Hulk a new arm and tells
them all that they must go fight Thanos
whatever the cost whatever it takes
Doctor Strange teleports them all to
where Thanos is and then it's everybody
versus Thanos Thanos using the Infinity
Gauntlet still manages to hold everybody
off but then Thor using Stormbreaker
manages to cut off Thanos as arm
Captain America runs to it grabs it puts
it on and then teleports Thanos
somewhere before the infinity gauntlet
power kills him the movie ends with
Captain America's funeral and Tony gives
a speech there after the funeral
Tony hands Bucky Captain America shield
and Bucky takes on the mantle of Captain
America
Hawkeye finally retires and he leaves
with his family leaving his bow behind
Thor goes to rule over his remaining as
guardians in Norway Bruce Banner says
that he needs to leave to find more
about his new powers being merged with
the Hulk now black would a leave saying
that she has some unfinished
business to attend do and Captain Marvel
will assemble the rest of the heroes
Doctor Strange is left with the Infinity
Gauntlet and takes it back to the
sanctum sanctorum so that is the
Avengers in-game full plot lake again
there's no way to tell if this is
legitimate or not but it does have a lot
of points that make a lot of sense the
beginning makes a lot of sense and it
lines up with the trailers that we've
already seen Captain Marvel showing up
to the avengers headquarters nebula and
tony making it back to earth and the
avengers going to fight Thanos one thing
that makes a lot of sense and that
actually answers a question that a lot
of people have been asking is that agent
Kline shows up with Nick Fury's pager
everyone has been wondering how exactly
the Avengers get Nick Fury's pager in
the post-credits scene of Captain Marvel
well Kline is one of Nick Fury's most
trusted agents and he is mentioned in
the post-credits scene of Avengers
infinity war so it would make sense that
he would track down Nick Fury's SUV and
find the pager lying on the ground right
in front of it and if the pager is
something that Nick Fury would carry
around with him all the time Klein would
at least know that the pager belonged to
him even if he didn't know what the
pager was for also the fight with feyo's
in the beginning of the movie makes a
lot of sense as well and adds up with
what we know we have the scene in the
trailer where all of the Avengers are in
the Bennet are flying to go fight Thanos
all except for banner and Tony and it
would make sense that Thanos severely
injures Captain Marvel in the footage
that we've seen Captain Marvel seems
very confident that she can defeat
Thanos but of course this is Thanos
we're talking about with a fully
functioning Infinity Gauntlet with all
of the Infinity stones it doesn't matter
who you are you're not going to defeat
Thanos when he has the Infinity Gauntlet
with all of the Infinity stones and this
is going to show that the Avengers
cannot just defeat Thanos and this is
why the need for time travel comes in
the time jump also makes sense as well
primarily because we see Natasha's hair
be blonde and some of the scenes in the
trailers and then red and the others so
it makes sense that some time passes by
and then ant-man pops out of the quantum
realm and explains time-travel to the
Avengers I've also heard from a few
other plot leaks that the Avengers will
somehow manage to make copies of the
Infinity stones so this lines up with
the other plot leagues and it also makes
sense because if the Avengers go back in
time and alter the events the future is
going to be drastically altered as well
and severely devastating things could
happen like Wanda and
silver never getting their powers and
never been in Avengers age of Ultron and
vision never come into life as well the
final battle also makes a lot of sense
as well because we've heard from the
actors themselves that there is going to
be a huge battle with over 25 heroes in
it and I think everybody also expects
the Fallen Avengers and heroes to come
back as well and fight Thanos at the end
of the movie Captain America dying kind
of adds up with everybody's speculation
that at least one of the main heroes is
going to die and sadly it is most likely
going to be Captain America because Tony
has pepper and they're supposed to get
married and Disney will most likely let
that happen so sadly it does seem like
Captain America is going to be the one
to go of course saving everybody else
and then Doctor Strange taking the
Infinity Gauntlet and the Infinity
stones at the end of the movie could set
up infinity watch and the Illuminati so
I'm definitely all for that happening at
the end of Avengers endgame so again
there are a lot of things that make
sense and line up with other plot leaks
and the trailers that we've gotten but
of course there's no way to know if this
is 100% legitimate or not but let me
know what you all think about this new
plot leak what do you think from this
plot leak is going to happen in Avengers
endgame let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and again a reminder
about my giveaway I'm giving away a
life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and a
glow-in-the-dark painting by glow by
beau you can check out his work at glow
by beau comm I'll put the link in the
description down below and of course be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on everything relating to Avengers
endgame and all things Marvel as always
thank you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]